هنا في مدينه تخوان المكسيكيه على الحدود
الامريكيه اجتمع الاف المهاجرين في سبيل
البحث عن حياه افضل حياه كانت مجرد حلم
لكنها اقتربت الان من ان تكون واقعا بعد
ان انهت الولايات المتحده العمل بالبند
الحادي والاربعين الذي سمح بمنع دخول
المهاجرين الى اراضيها منذ بدايه وباء
كورونا
في مارس 2020 شهدت الولايات المتحده موجه
انتشار واسع للفيروس ما دفع الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب بموجب حال الطوارئ الصحيه
الى طرد الاشخاص الذين عبروا الى الولايات
المتحده بشكل غير قانوني على الفور
فوفقا لقانون البند الثاني والاربعين اعيد
ملايين المهاجرين الى اوطانهم في عمليه
استغرقت 10 دقائق فقط لكل مهاجر بحسب
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز لمنعهم من فرصه طلب
اللجوء واستخدم القانون رقم 42 بالفعل من
قبل مسؤول الهجره الامريكيين نحو مليونين
ونصف المليون مره على الحدود الجنوبيه
لطرد الاشخاص الى المكسيك او الى وطنهم
دون تقييم فردي لجميع احتياجاتهم وفقا
لتقرير اممي وسمح ايضا بالابعاد السريع
لحوالي 30 الف شخص من فنزويلا وايييتي
وكوبا ونيكاراغوا الى المكسيك كل شهر هذه
الاجراءات هو زياده استخدام عمليات
الابعاد العاجل لقيت انتقادات شديده من
قبل جماعه حقوق الانسان الذين شددوا على
انها تتعارض مع حظر الطرد الجماعي ومبدا
عدم الاعاده القسريه لكن رغم ذلك ظلت
ترامب مصرا عليها لكي يسيطر على مواصفاتها
بازمات الهجره والان مع تولي جو بايدن
رئاسه منذ عامين لا تزال القواعد المتعلقه
بالهجره معضله معقده فما بعد انهاء
القانون رقم 42 الرئيس بايدن اكد ان الوضع
سيكون فوضويا لبعض الوقت على الحدود
المكسيكيه واستعدادا لذلك فرضت اداره بادن
قيودا جديده على حق اللجوء وحشدت اكثر من
24 من عناصر قوات الامن محذره اننا الحدود
مع المكسيك لم تفتح بعد
ورجح خبراء اعاده القانون رقم ثمانيه الى
حيز التنفيذ في ظل اداره بايدن المعروفه
بسياسات الهجره الاكثر ليونه وعلى عكس
البند الثاني والاربعين تستغرق اجراءات
الهجره بموجب البند الثامن عده ساعات كما
تزيد من فرص المهاجرين في التاهل للحصول
على اللجوء بدلا من الرفض الفوري
من جانبهم وخوفا من تدفق المهاجرين يضغط
الجمهوريون لتمديد صلاحيه القانون الثاني
والاربعين ويسعون لاستكمال جدار ترامب
الشهير
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات